you like trains Paris London takes you
two hours seated in a comfortable
compartment your goods cover 11,000
kilometers twice as quickly as by ship
and the ecologist inside you smiles at
the thought that you are using one of
the greenest means of travel on the
market you think that is excellent but
we are here to tell you it could be much
better provided that it is transformed
into a standardized competitive and
better manage sector track 1 promote
interoperability in other words allow
trains to move through and across all of
Europe without any technical regulatory
or operational constraints because at
the moment the signalling changes
virtually from one country to the next
the talus PBK for example goes across
seven different types of signaling zones
07 zones that's cool happens to be the
number of chakras is except that a
single standard would be much simpler
and above all cheaper do this at the
moment the losses due to realization of
trains and different countries and
measured in millions but where was I i
yes attract to separate the railway
operators from the network managers
think about it airports are not managed
by Airlines and neither are motorways
managed by Road for years so why should
it be different for rail gave you Alice
if I ASEAN
cisely what's more this would improve
the transplant shoe allottee just like
opening up the railway market to
competition will guarantee a wider
choice of services and who says a wider
choice of services also says satisfied
and happy users and that's track 3 this
according to our information would be
appreciated by a large a very large
number of you ultimately it would just
take a few reforms to transform a
labyrinth of national services into a
single European railway network the
railway network of the future